it's obviously not the first time that
the European commission has looked at um
imposing competition penalties on large
US tech firms a few years ago Microsoft
was in the
crosshairs I think when you look at the
way the EU sees big organizations such
as Google and Microsoft and Yahoo uh is
that they may be attempting to challenge
their dominance for a number of reasons
economic political um part one of one of
the reasons might partly be that the US
firms have been so successful in this
area have grown their businesses in such
a dramatic way in a fairly deregulated
internet economy that the European uh
competitors are really struggling to
keep up and so this might might be seen
by some as an attempt to give the
European uh companies a chance to catch
up it has to all be seen in a political
context there's obviously a very large
trade deal currently being negotiated
between the EU and the US there's a lot
of political disc
discussions it also has to be seen in
the context of intelligence and data
Gathering and the power of these large
tech companies to hold information about
EU citizens and possibly give it up to
security agencies now in light of what
Edward Snowden came out with last year
the European authorities are very very
sensitive to the Privacy angle here so
it's a general challenge to US tech
businesses it's a political challenge
but it's also an eon an economic
one